welcome everyone to my talk this is juan
from acuity
so today we are going to talk about
cloud native distributed machine
learning pipelines at scale
first of all a little bit introduction
about myself
i'm a funding engineer at acuity.io
we are the enterprise company for the
argo project under cncf
i've been very actively contributing and
maintaining projects in the open source
community
for mlm frameworks i've been maintaining
projects like xgboost tensorflow metric
learn
that's currently in cyclic long country
also from infrastructure side i've been
maintaining projects like argo workflows
and kobe flow
and there are a couple of books that i
authored
the first book distributed machine
learning patterns is currently still in
draft but it's available on many mip
which means that you can read it for
free online in your browser
and feel free to contact me
i'm on twitter and linkedin you can
contact me
while that handle
feel free to schedule chat with me if
necessary
so today's agenda first of all we will
be talking about the components of
distributed machine learning pipelines
and then we'll talk about
python scientific ecosystem and the
existing workflow orchestration tools in
python
and then we'll talk about cloud-native
kubernetes explain what those are
and after that we'll talk about
kubernetes native machine learning
pipelines
and
last but not least
we will talk about how we can stay
stronger together and the future outlook
by combining those ecosystems together
so what are the components of
distributed machine learning pipelines
the first part is the data ingestion and
data pre-processing
you may encounter things like batching
and caching streaming if
you are working on a streaming based
data set
and you may perform some feature
engineering
and perhaps require some future stores
in order to
make the model training and model
serving more consistent
and make your features starts engineered
to be better served in production
the second part is the distributed model
training
and which would involve
maybe hyper parameter tuning and model
selection or neural architectural search
for deep learning models
and in order to run distributed model
training
in a distributed environment you have to
select particular training strategies so
for example parameter server based
training strategies and all reduced or
collected communication
strategies
and this is all sorts of optimizations
you can do while scheduling techniques
for example priority and game scheduling
elastic scheduling if you are running
your distributed model training
workloads on pre-empt spot
instances
and next is the model serving component
uh you may want to replicate your model
serving services
if you have a large number of
model serving requests you can shut your
services into different
shots to handle very large model serving
requests
and there's also even driven processing
as well
and last but not least there's workflow
orchestration that's required to chain
all the steps together
into a complete end-to-end distributed
machine learning pipelines
also check out the distributed machine
learning patterns book that i mentioned
uh it includes many of the patterns
we are
will talk about in this presentation as
well
let's take a look at the python
scientific ecosystem
at the very bottom and its core is a
python language
and on top of that there are core
libraries like numpy matplotlib
scipy pandas to help with numerical
computations scientific computations
data frame data manipulations and so on
and then on top of that there are
specialized libraries such as psychic
learn for machine learning
stats models for
performing statistics in python
and tasks for parallel computation and
orchestration
and at the very top there are domain
specific python
libraries for example astral pi for
astronomy
pi m c3
for
probabilistic statistics
and then there are a lot of tools that
are written natively in python here the
python native means that
everything's implemented in python
without
any other languages and so on so here
there are three popular workflow
acquisition tools
in the community
that you can choose from
in order to chain all the steps together
in your machine learning pipeline
so what is cloud native and kubernetes
or k8s you also say
in kubernetes
so i came across this uh container
coloring book for kids
during kubicon north america a couple of
weeks ago and this is a great book for
kids
for coloring but also a great book for
others to explain and understand various
concepts around cloud native and
kubernetes
so imagine
once upon a time
there were three little pigs they each
needed a place to leave
and obviously there are a lot of options
for them you can choose a house or
duplex or an apartment or even living in
the park
so consider imagine
a little piggy is an application
an application need to choose a place to
run right
so application may choose a house which
is the most secure because
if any of uh if this particular house
is ever
broken into the rest of the houses the
other apartments houses are still safe
but
if each of the little piggy lives in a
separate house that means more
maintenance for all the houses
so think of piggies
as applications they live in containers
different isolated environments
and once you move to your apartment you
need to buy different furnitures and
appliances that meet your daily
requirements in order to achieve high
living standards maybe
so this is
so in other words the resources
needs to be managed
inside the containers
so kubernetes that's where kubernetes
comes into play kubernetes automates the
deployment scaling and management
of containerized applications
so make lives easier for those little
pvps
what does the kubernetes native machine
learning workflow look like
first let's talk about the argo project
the aqua project consists a set of
kubernetes native tools for deploying
and running applications managing
clusters and do githubs right
githubs are
in a in a sense that we are storing
everything in git we are versioning
everything making sure
uh git contains the source of truth to
reflect your infrastructure
so there are four core projects under
argo
first the first project is the argo
workflows it's the kubernetes native
workflow engine
and then argo events is the event-based
dependency management for kubernetes
there's also argo cd which is for
decorative continuous delivery with a
fully loaded ui that's needed for almost
every developers in this area
so that they can just take a look at the
ui to see what's happening in their
clusters and so on
and last but not least
this argo rollouts project that provides
advanced kubernetes progressive
deployment strategies
and the algo project is used and trusted
by more than 180 end-user companies
000 slack members
1 000 contributors to
the code base
more than 20k guitar stars
and the project this is a diagram from
cncf
that that provides a project rankings
for developer velocity based on project
activity
such as
the activities on pull requests
issues number of commits and so on and
argo is one of the fastest growing uh
and developing projects in the cncf
foundation
argo workflows
so let's talk first talk about argo
workflows it's the connect container
native workflow engine for kubernetes
the main use cases for other workflows
are machine learning pipelines data
processing etl
infrastructure automation
continuous delivery and integration
here's a screenshot of what
the auger workflows ui looks like
workflows contains
a set of
crds
and controllers
that are
kubernetes native so crds are kubernetes
custom resources
for example that natively integrates
with other kubernetes resources such as
volume and secrets and so on
and other workflows provides interfaces
such as cri server ui
as well as python java sdks
the cri is useful to manage workflows
and perform operations such as
submitting suspending deleting workflows
through command line and the server is
used for
for integrating with other services
rest or grpc interfaces
and the ui is useful to manage and
visualize workflows
and artifacts created
for the workflows
the logs and resource usage analytics
and stuff and so on
here's a basic hello world example of
our argo workflow
so we basically specify the container
image and the command to run
for this workflow
and this example on the left hand side
is a custom resource uh created
so we specify a customer's resource
for other workflows to submit to the
kubernetes cluster
so you can submit any kubernetes native
resources
to
kubernetes cluster on the right hand
side that's perhaps the most useful to
the python community
you can specify a python script
uh
providing the source code for example
here we are generating some random
numbers using the python uh offering
image
you can also specify this as a container
if you like
such as in the hello world example you
can just specify the exact python code
command to run
instead
here's an example of
a dag
created by argo workflows so a dag is a
directed acyclic
graph
that consists of steps
so for example here
this dag consists of a b c d steps and
each of them have
has their own dependencies for example
step c depends on
step a and step d depends on b and c
and this is a visualization provided by
the argo workflows ui
and here is a simple coin flip example
to showcase the conditional
syntax so here we can specify the
condition
to
to say uh whether
we want to run the next step or not so
for example here we run flip coin step
first which is the python script we just
saw
and if the result
returns hats then we run
the template called heads
which
also prints another
log saying it was has
otherwise we print it was tails
so we specified these conditionals
inside the wing clause
in the different steps
well there's a lot of yaml files and
yama files everywhere
can we do everything in python
of course
we want to keep calm and coding python
right
so we got a lot of options so the first
option is could be flow
pipelines so could be full of pipelines
it's a sub project under the copy flow
project
it's
purposely designed for machine learning
pipelines
using kubiflow
and the second project is cooli cooley
is a unified interface for constructing
and managing workflows
in different backends for example aggro
workflows
and algo workflows also
maintains its official
python sdk but rather low level but you
can interact
with other features uh that's provided
by other other workflows
so a quick example using cooley
if you want to build a cooley uh
coin flip
uh workflow in python this is how it
looks
that's very different from the yaml that
we see
so here we define a python function
and we
define the flip coin function step that
runs that particular python function
and here are the heads and tails
step
both of them are defined in terms of a
coolly run container
and we can call flip coin step
and
check whether its result is equal to
heads or tails
and call the responding uh the
corresponding
steps for heads and tails
conditionally
and here is how it looks like for a dag
defined in cooley pythons decay
so you define a generic
python function called job that runs a
container
you can specify the name of the job
so this can be reused for multiple steps
so here for example we are
building a very simple
dag
that has a linear relationship for
example b depends on
uh
a b depends on a and d depends on b
c depends on a
under that example
as well
so here we can use cooley.deck
to specify the dependencies altogether
to build a diamond shaped
workflow
next i want to talk about argo events
it's the event driven workflow
automation framework
currently it supports events
from 20 more than 20 event sources such
as
webhooks s3 gcp pops up beat slack etc
and it supports
more than 10 triggers so based on
if anything uh new
from if we receive any new events from
those event sources we trigger
we can trigger things like kubernetes
with our native objects we can trigger
an argo workflow we can trigger
aws lambda kafka
slack messages and so on
so we can use argo events to manage
everything from simple linear real time
to complex multi-source events
and other events is also cloud events
compliant so uh so that you can use this
um standard common specification to
integrate with other systems very easily
so what would do what would a typical
workflow look like with other workflows
and events
um
so here let's assume
uh we are watching
events from github so for example events
like comments pull requests tags and so
on so argo events
is responsible to rewatch and receive
those events
once it receives events it will trigger
work machine learning pipeline with
aggro workflow
so in other words the
uh argo events triggers
a pipeline that's defined and chained
together by other workflows
so a simple workflow may look like this
uh the data ingestion
that's responsible to ingest data from
the data source
you may have a cache store that's in
place using aggro kubernetes
to check whether the data has been
updated or not recently in order to
skip this particular data ingestion step
if nothing changes in the data set
otherwise you have to
execute that data ingestion from scratch
which with a lot of resources
and after that
after we've ingested the data
uh we start model training right so
model training can uh we can have
multiple workers and
multiple data shots uh to uh so here for
example we are
running the distributed model training
using will reduce
um uh we will zoom into that uh uh
soon
so the model training may consist of
code written in tensorflow pytorch and
so on
and then
uh you can use could be flow to
uh submit a distributed tensorflow
training jobs uh so that um
developers algorithm developers don't
have to worry about the infrastructure
side of things
kubiflo will communicate with kubernetes
uh to request enough resources for each
of the workers uh parameter servers and
so on and then tensorflow can just focus
on uh the
algorithms
the models and so on
there's also a project a sub project
called cutip in cooperflow that's used
for for hyperparameter tuning and neural
architectural search
early stopping and so on written
natively
in kubernetes
so you can use all the tools
available
to build a really cloud native
kubernetes
native container native
machine learning pipeline
in your distributed kubernetes cluster
a little bit more details on the
distributed model training side um
so you can have multiple workers each of
the workers consume
a particular data partition
from the data partitions
that you partition
ahead of time from the data source
so this diagram is taken from my
distributed machine learning patterns
book if you're interested please take a
look
you can read it free online
last but not least we are going to
mention that we should stay stronger
together by combining what's the best
of other ecosystems
so in the future
we
as data scientists we can
our developers we can focus on
developing tools that are most valuable
for scientists for example
uh specialized algorithms specialized
uh
numeric computation
algorithms and so on such as circuit
learner tensorflow
we can
embrace the kubernetes ecosystem
so
there are many ways to do that there are
kubernetes native operators and custom
resources
for example provided by uh for example
kubiflow provides custom resources and
operators
on kubernetes
so that you can run tensorflow jobs pi
touch jobs in a distributed fashion very
easily on kubernetes
and aggro workflows provides custom
resources and controllers
to help
orchestrate your jobs
for to earth
to achieve
the maximum benefits brought by our
kubernetes
and there are projects that integrate
well with kubernetes for example dusk
ray and spark they all have their own
operators
that could help the frameworks to run on
kubernetes as well
in other words uh in the future the the
architecture will be more decoupled uh
into uh different areas uh
focuses for example
for an infrastructure
side the architecture could focus on ml
ops devops or data ops
that's focusing on data set and features
stores those kind of things
and there are frameworks are
architectures so for example a machine
learning framework
deep learning frameworks or data
visualization frameworks scientific
computing frameworks they are
they are uh
they are they are the they are focusing
on the framework itself instead of
focusing from the infrastructure
worrying about different cloud providers
different cloud vendors
domain specific
experience
and so on
and here are some screenshots for
the first one on the top is the lfei and
data landscape that contains a lot of
ai and data related projects
and at the bottom
there is this is cncf cloud native
interactive landscape so this landscape
contains
a lot of projects that are cloud in the
cloud native
scope so
i think most of them are called native
uh and kubernetes native as well and
they tend to play well with each other
so by combining the best from both of
these communities
for example our ai community data
community uh cloud native communities
pi data communities we can
focus on what's the best what brings the
best benefits to our scientists
that's it for the presentation and feel
free to contact me by email i have the
same handle on almost all the social
media
and feel free to schedule a chat if
necessary to talk about open source and
any potential or collaboration
and you are welcome to join the argo
community and the kubiflow community to
talk about how to contribute and how to
get involved or send us back back
reports visual enhancements
and so on
thank you for listening